some defenders of Trump like to say hey
you know liberals should like him more
because he's not a crazy religious
conservative he's really just a business
guy it may be true that Trump's personal
social views are not extreme but he is
pandering to the most extreme regressive
retrograde elements of the Republican
Party and he's capping that off this
weekend by attending this ridiculous
anti LGBT event called rediscovering God
in America this is happening in Florida
this totally abortive conference was
founded by David Lane of the American
renewal project and I've mentioned this
before Louis this is that project that
wants to try to get right-wing pastors
to run for office at all levels to just
fill government with right-wing
Christian pastors that's sort of the
goal and David Lane was interviewed by
Bloomberg and said that he intends to
quiz Donald Trump about how he plans to
fight quote homosexual totalitarianism
and the gay rights militants both
completely imaginary problems in the
u.s. so I'm glad that they're gonna
start off by focusing on things that
just don't exist yeah well this is
something that Trump needs to do when
you run as a Republican this is the kind
of stuff you're involved in whether you
believe it or not you have to pander to
these people and you have to try and get
their vote and it is a pretty disturbing
platform they have I mean it's bad
enough that we have so few scientists
and engineers and those types of people
running for office and now they want to
throw a bunch of pastors at us
scary Lane is a vocal opponent of LGBT
equality he said that gay people praying
at a presidential inauguration back in
2012 might cause car bombs in Los
Angeles DC and Des Moines Iowa as a sign
of God's judgement about the pagan
onslaught of the LGBT rights movement
again all stuff that just doesn't exist
didn't happen according to the
invitation posted by the group Liberty
Council action some of the speakers at
this some of the luminaries to speak at
this event will be mat Staver of Liberty
Council he's the guy who represented
bigoted Kentucky County Clerk Kim Davis
this Staver last month denounced
memorial gatherings for the victims of
the orlando nightclub attack as
homosexual love fests he has also
claimed that gay people are demonic and
looking to abuse children David Barton
will be speaking at this conference he's
a right-wing nut who calls himself a
historian he thinks that God is
preventing a cure for AIDS because it's
a divine penalty for homosexuality of
course ignoring that we are very very
close to an AIDS vaccine and also
speaking at this conference will be
Maine pastor Ken Graves who preaches
against what he calls militant homo
fascism and lastly Bill Federer a
religious right activist and conspiracy
theorist who thinks that gay rights are
bringing about the Islamic takeover of
America I never get that Louis because
the Islamists hate gays how is it that
they're bringing on a gay take over that
is a great question
I don't know this reminds me of when I
maybe it was Newt Gingrich said that
Muslims atheist Muslims are gonna take
over the country and force atheism on
people right it's uh they don't think
about what they say they just they just
say things when I hear people say hey
Trump is actually pretty good for the
LGBT community for a Republican what I'm
hearing is Trump doesn't seem to
personally care about gay people one way
or the other and he also doesn't want
them murdered so in that sense for a
Republican he's he's not a bad guy I
guess well that's it is a huge step up
for many many many Republicans yes I was
looking at some news articles about this
this morning and on the right wing
websites I read comments sort of I'm
paraphrasing here but basically hey at
least it's not illegal to be gay in the
US and you don't get killed like you do
in Iran so it's like a very very low bar
for saying you know I think things are
good enough for gay people they're not
getting killed here and it's at least
not barred legally from from from from
existing in the pub in public society
it's sort of sad actually that the bar
is being set that low for some of these
right-wingers yeah but while there's
while there's some truth to that it's
it's we're well past that and so
if you want to bring that up in other
countries by all means it's hugely
important but that is their bar and it's
it yeah it's bad after the break I'm
going to speak to attorney Mike
Papantonio the latest on his cases
against DuPont for this horribly toxic
chemical CH that is produced it's a
byproduct of the production of that
nonstick coating Teflon and we will talk
to Mike Papantonio about how dating all
the way back to 1961 DuPont had at least
some reason to believe this stuff c8 was
not good for people's health